i'm going to start with the most
important question right up front um who
is better at chess you or jason
i was absolutely and there's no no
debate in that at all jace is terrible
and i'm pretty good
right does he ever does he actually ever
beat you
he cheats i mean he'll be he'll beat me
if he cheats
yeah i mean of course you'll hear her i
hope you i hope you interview him later
because you'll hear a very different
story nobody's a shocking cheat yeah
shocking cheek actually shocking chess
player it's not what he thinks
i will definitely bring up the fact that
you said that he cheats um when i i'm
joking obviously well maybe i will bring
it no no no no no no bring that up
i definitely will uh if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
directed what is the first thing you'd
like them to watch and why
well i think it's a it's a frequency
thing really i think if someone dials
into the frequency then you'll probably
you'll probably like
most of my work i suspect
um and
in terms of uh a hierarchy of of what
movie uh i'm not sure if i've got one
um
you know what i quite like is this
momentum i've got at the moment because
i'm talking
i quite like you got one movie that
you're very keen on then and then quite
swiftly i mean i think i used to make
one movie every three years or something
and and now i'm sort of making two
movies every year
and
it means you can move quickly and you
can have some
objectivity because you're not too
frustrated about
pushing in so much energy into one
project
that you can
you can care too much
so
i'm not sure if there's a hierarchy i
just
uh
i i like i probably like the movie the
most that i did the last
i'm very much enjoying your uh output
recently uh i i
i'm i say keep going please i will keep
walking i will keep watching them um if
you could i know that everyone i would
imagine when you want to make a movie
you can get the financing but has there
been a project along the way that you
really wanted to do and you couldn't get
the financing like if you could get the
financing for anything tomorrow what
would you want to make
no i don't it does it for me it doesn't
work like that for me it's a conspiracy
of events that have to
collide or
moving concert and then you capitalize
on a premise
a moment in time the freedom that you
have
whether you've made anything like that
recently there seems to be a lot of
different components
that uh go into the sort of attic of
your mind and you get you do this sort
of
intuitive arithmetic
do we fancy this about now and you know
it two years earlier you may have not
fancied the project at all
um
you know i didn't see myself making
aladdin until the sudden the the um
it provoked me by uh how
alien and exotic that idea was
so
i i i
it's hard to know what you're motivated
by but you said to go oh i like that oh
i haven't done that that's a new
completely new genre can we make that
work
and i think the more you pick up rhythm
and confidence in that you can sort of
start bouncing around all over the place
and hopefully take some kind of
consistency with your frequency
throughout your work i'm i'm always i'm
fascinated by the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together
which of your films actually went
through the biggest changes in the
editing room that perhaps you weren't
expecting
well i mean i'm always expecting because
i
i know you're going to watch that film
and it's not going to be the film
your tonality is probably going to be
what you set out
so you're the the
the the the general expression and fro
and tone of what it was you meant to
make
is usually pretty consistent you'll be
within five percent of what it was that
you went when
what you wanted to make but there will
be
you can realize you you afterwards in
retrospect that if
there are things that you can do to
improve the efficiency of the narrative
and the the journey itself
um
if you can follow the breadcrumbs to the
bakery
you can sometimes improve the bread
crumbs
um
in order for you to
to end up in that bakery elegantly or
more elegantly and that's usually
remedied with a few days additional
photography at the end where you can sit
there marinade on it and i think that's
been the same with all of my projects
i've always
i've let i've left about four or four
four or five days
of which is usually three that you need
to
to consolidate
uh
ideas that
that can be made more efficient
um in terms of plot and so on and i
think they're they're all pretty much
consistent in that sense
i don't think i don't think one has been
more work than the other i am a big fan
of uh you when you work with jason so
what do i need to do to get you to make
ten more movies with jason actually
nothing i'll be very happy it's funny
i'm about to go make a film in spain and
i would have done it with jason
um apart from he's just far too old now
and he's just creeps around and he sort
of needs crutches and i needed someone
handsome and young
so i went for someone else
otherwise i would i would use him the
whole time
so
next time i'm looking for an old man who
creeks around and crutches you'll see me
using jason again
that won't be that way long
i'm glad to hear that uh i've seen you
work on set and i'm just curious um with
operation fortune how much is like
actually scripted on something like this
and how much are you like tweaking
everything on set on the day to finagle
exactly what you want uh because i saw
you do it on man from uncle and and the
second uh sherlock holmes movies and i
could see the way you were tweaking
things and i'm just curious if it's
still the same
yeah it is it's pretty much the same i
think probably more so on this one than
than almost any other script that i've
done
um
i didn't like the script when i started
with the script
and and that was sort of the challenge
it was it was something that i cobbled
up with a couple of chaps that uh that
i worked with
and
it was it was a bit of a feathery fish
and the challenge was how to make it a
less feathery fish and so we just
rewrote every every scene
uh on the day in this film almost
completely
uh you had general ideas which were fun
like the danny francesco idea that you
take out a movie star as a spy you'd
hold on to those as
base camps for your summit
but uh how you got to those base camps
was was completely spontaneous on the
day
you just knew you had to get to that
base camp um i have to bring up with you
because i am such a fan of the first two
sherlock holmes movies do you think that
there's ever going to be a third one or
is it sort of that time has come and
gone
well honestly i left this up to robert
so robin wanted to be in charge of this
um
so
it's uh that the ball's in his court so
he's in charge of the script he's in
charge of the whole thing so i've i've
moon walked out of that until uh
until there's a time for me to get
involved
same question with uh aladdin i
obviously it's the biggest hit of i
believe your career um it made like over
a billion dollars do you do you actually
see yourself doing a sequel
i'd very much like to i can't tell you
how much i enjoyed that experience
um
it was a great experience uh that whole
disney thing as you can imagine is
is such a it's such a professional
outfit just from that perspective it was
so much fun i would i would i would very
much like to we'll we'll wait and see we
have been kicking some ideas around for
some time now but uh it'd be great to do
it'd be great to go back there yeah i
have to stop there i'm just going to say
it is really awesome to talk with you
again and hopefully next time i will get
even more time i have a million
questions and i just want to thank you
for operation fortune i really had fun
watching it last night thank you very
much indeed thank you good to see you
again
you